I'd like to introduce Karen Page
and Andrew Doernenburg, um, to uh,
talk today where we're, we're going to
talk a little bit about their new book,
which is in front of me,
kitchen creativity, but this
is also their 11th book.
And I've been using your
books for multiple years as
inspiration from when I was
first cooking, but also now to help
provide inspiration to our chefs, uh,
in our units around the world at Google.
So thank you first for being
here and making time to see us.
It's a true pleasure,
but a little bit about authors
before we dive into the book.
And we would like to make this
a, uh, kind of a conversation.
So as you have questions that come up,
typically leave it to the end,
but if there's something that you have a
tidbit you really want to get out there,
please let us know.
We'd love to make this a conversation
and we're going to do a quick interview
and then we're going to break
into what we do at kitchen sink,
which is our teaching kitchen. And we're
going to do some cooking and chef, dd.
And the team are going to put together
a delicious treat and you look at the
sample it. So that's always a plus. Um, so
a little bit about, uh, about our authors.
So, uh, for Karen on my right here,
after skipping a grade care and
received her letter of admissions to
Northwestern, university of age 16,
the first person to do the whole thing.
And I know, right? Well you're the
first person to attend college, um,
self financed your education, uh,
with seven academic scholarships.
Super Cool. Uh, you ran your own
birthday cake delivery business.
Love to hear more about that.
Later on,
you were awarded a Ba in economics and
certified in the women's studies from
Northwestern university and he three
named one of six honorable mentions and
glamorous top 10 college women competition
and featured on the cover of Newsweek
as well.
You were invited to the White House twice
back in [inaudible] 86 you also earn
an Mba from Harvard business
school, uh, Northwestern named you.
And then you three, one
of the universities, 100
leading professional alumni.
Congratulations, council
of 100 right on, uh,
an avid meditator. Uh, you both like
to run. Uh, interesting to hear that.
And you live in New York City with
your husband to your right. Andrew.
So welcome Karen, great
to have you here. And uh,
Mr Andrew grew up in the bay area here.
Great to see another bay area
I individual. Um, and you,
you kind of transitioned from farmland
to suburbs, so your families, uh, um,
background and backyard
had a lot of trees. You're
obviously into gardening and,
and kind of led you into the culinary
world where you started cooking at a young
age.
And uh,
you were mentioned as first cooking at
Mcdonald's in your early years as well
as,
uh,
one of the few like Jeff Bezos and others
and also worked at Mcdonald's doing
quite well. Now from a time
you're adulation. Cute. Everyone,
everyone has their, their start
somewhere. That's awesome. Uh,
three days out of high school
you became a firefighter. Um,
so obviously with the amazing devastation
and in northern California with the
fires lately, um, it's great
to see that you were, um,
putting in your dues early on,
but at the same time found that
after awhile a firefighting was, uh,
even though it was your best
day of putting out fires
and cooking for the team,
your best days ahead, we're really getting
into the kitchen, see, became a chef.
You worked in some amazingly
talented, uh, restaurants, um,
worked under some top
chefs and then after, uh,
deciding to leave the kitchen. So you
worked with lady a shower for a while,
for a while,
decided to leave the kitchen and then I
ended up putting together some amazing
books that we're going to
talk about in a moment.
You also earned your som certificate.
Interesting Tidbit and sure,
yes, yes. At the same time.
No, at different times.
I think it's an important part of
anybody's culinary education. Absolutely.
Absolutely worthwhile.
And then, um, interesting, uh,
piece as well as you followed a,
your was it your grandmother's left for,
to photography and d might run,
mother actually had a dark room,
which you probably have no idea. Yes.
But it was a place where
you developed film,
which you probably have no idea what,
that there was a time where that happened.
Yes. That's my fault. So you and you
did all the photographs for the buck,
is that correct? For this one or this
one then? Vege Flavor Bible. Yeah,
that's right. Yeah. So Ma Ma multitalented
individual Sarah on the room. Indeed.
So it, it's, it's my distinct pleasure and
total excitement. I can't say it enough.
We talked to ned copy for the last
hour and how excited I was to,
to see you guys here.
Please welcome her authors.
[inaudible]
I can't have to interject by
saying, first of all, Scott,
thank you for that and
amazing introduction.
I was worried we're going to be here for
hours if you're starting out just like
Steve, but that was lovely. Um,
but the reason that we're here is
actually because of this man. And, um, we,
I haven't had the pleasure of meeting him
in person before, but, um, we have been,
uh, in the email and email
touch and in virtual touch, um,
ever since he gave this
wonderful interview to this
national magazine where he
mentioned one of our books,
his, uh, his, uh, favorite book,
which we actually got to see today,
which was thrilling and
it gets bound together.
What were you describing
with butcher string?
Yeah, so kind of fallen
apart. This is priceless.
So if anyone tries to take this from me,
good luck.
This is the first edition culinary router
street and it is in the same condition
as it was 17 years ago when you signed it.
It was literally signed in 2000.
And it was a book that I used,
um,
for inspiration on a day to day
level when I was writing menus.
And we're going to talk about how chefs
and gain their inspiration and I'll call
Ariens and, and even home chefs,
home cooks gain their inspiration.
And there's such a variety of
techniques in becoming creative.
But this book is something
that's very near and dear to me.
And when I brought it out to Andrew
when he was dining at our restaurant,
I humbly said it's, it's getting used as
you can see the binding's falling off.
So my only feedback for the publisher
is a stronger binding here cause the
butcher's twine is not quite
working or duct tape included.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
But inspiration,
I mean part of our inspiration for being
here is really Scott and the amazing
reputation that Google has
for its culinary program.
And to know that you've been here for
how many years now is it both your,
that you have helped to have a raise it
to a really a world class level when you
started out there was just
I think a handful of cafes
and now, you know, they're,
they are all over the world.
Um,
but for those of us who've never eaten
any Google before, this is a first,
um,
to know that it is legendary in
terms of the choices available,
the quality of the food and now being
here at this wonderful new location that
we understand just opened, um, a
matter of weeks ago. Really. Um, it's,
it's something that gets us on a plane
from New York City to come out to the bay
area to see what it's all about. And
the fact that we, if we had any role,
um, the most, my new role and,
and being an inspiration to you,
then we're thrilled to be able to be,
to be here with all the Googlers for
the first time. So thanks for having me.
I often talk about, um, your books.
Obviously this has just
been released a week ago.
So many of you probably
you're flipping through it,
but a lot of your books
follow that same thing theme,
which is to really unlock the creativity
and the potential in chefs' minds.
And again, whether it's a professional
chef or whether it's shops at home.
And what I found that these books are so
amazing at is I always say it's hard to
plan to be creative on a specific day.
You know,
you can book the time in
your calendar and say,
on Wednesday I'm going to write a menu.
But you know, you don't feel well,
the weather's bad. Something comes
up in the news and you're just,
you're not feeling it.
Tell me how this book is helping chefs
and individuals kind of overcome that.
There's,
there's a lot of great pieces in there,
but maybe unpack a little bit of some of
the initial thoughts that you put into
this book to help chefs and home chefs
really kind of get that creative edge and
bring their best forward.
Well, I think it's true that
for any of those who cook,
whether it's at home or professionally,
um,
you're always looking for inspiration
and there's a lot of sameness.
Otherwise it takes place when you're
making the same thing day in and day out.
So if you can learn to bring
creativity or you're cooking,
it's going to add that
much more enjoyment to you,
to everybody that you're cooking
for and with. Um, but beyond that,
it's really a matter of the creativity
is the most important skill that we can
possibly have.
And so if you can learn the skill of
creativity from the world's best chefs,
what better way to learn it? We had, um,
done research on the fact that CEOs are
saying that the number one skill for
success in leadership and in businesses
creativity, it's not integrity,
it's not global thinking, which
is a little interesting. Um,
but the fact that it's
creativity makes it a study,
a subject that's worth
studying. And so, uh,
we also realized that the only one in
four people survey say that they think
that they're at their creative potential.
So to the extent that we
can become more creative,
it's something we can
apply to our daily lives.
It's something we can
imply it in the kitchen.
And so what we did with kitchen creativity
is we wanted to create the ultimate
culinary brainstorming tool.
So if you want to be more creative,
what are some of the things that you can
use some of the best practices and used
by the world's best chefs to become
more creative and really, um,
we map out the process of creativity,
which I know we're going to get into, but,
um, both in a general way. Um,
in terms of culinarily coming up
with a new dish, I'm trying to, uh,
take old dishes and make them new again.
Um,
but then also from just a
best practices standpoint,
how do you let your creativity flow?
And we've got some advice from some of
the leading creativity experts in the
world talking about how
to make that happen.
Yeah. It so don't, don't downplay that.
I think one of the things that, uh,
gotten me excited about culinary artist
for me when I looked at a years ago was
the pedigree of chefs you have in
your, in your back pocket. I mean,
I'm interested to hear how you informed,
is it some of the initial relationship
with these shops and when you're talking
about every top shop out there,
whether it's Danco repair, uh,
Danny Meyer's restaurant,
or you've got amazing chefs that are
taking their time to share some of their
most intimate secrets on what's
made them successful. Um,
and I don't take that lightly and none
of our chefs at Google that do such an
amazing job and bringing the food
program to live here. Do either,
I mean these are the inspirational
chefs that they look to aspire to be.
What were some of the initial,
how did that happen?
Like what was that first chef you're like,
oh my God,
if I could just get this right.
How did that go about? When we started
out, we had never written a book before.
And so how do you get the world's
best chefs to talk to you?
We didn't really know,
but the ace in our home was that Andrew
was working as a professional chef in
Boston and he was working with
Chris Schlesinger and Lidia Shyer,
who at the time or two of the best chefs
in the country who happened to be in
Boston.
And so having,
starting out with the two of them
and then he went on to work with Anne
Rosenzweig at a Arcadia in New York City.
And once we had the three
of them in our pocket,
we can kind of go to people because there
was three big names that they knew us
personally. They had some belief
that we could actually write a book.
And so they thought,
well,
if Lydia is Ann and Chris isn't an
ANZ and then you know, I'm into.
So from there we went to other top chefs
in Boston, in New York. From then, um,
we were doing the research
on weekends and evenings.
We would travel to San Francisco
and knocking Gary Danko store.
Actually he would also
work with metal in it,
that Matt and Cam and the up at the
school for American chefs at or vineyards
where Gary, when Gary Danco,
we met others. Jeff's through her too. But
the key is Karen writes a great letter.
That's how you do. She goes, well, we
just interviewed these other people.
Would you like to be
included in our new book?
And even though they didn't know us,
they knew the other people. It's like,
and also asking for 15 minutes
who only need 15, 20 minutes.
And that always almost always turned
into an hour. And I'll never forget,
we interviewed the chef Barbara Tropp,
a legendary restaurant tour shaft,
China Moon Cafe in San Francisco.
And at the end we,
we talked to her for like
almost an hour and a half years.
I've never had a conversation like
this and we're like neither of weight.
And then she says, well, try
not to edit my words too much,
where like you went to Princeton,
you're good.
Yes, she's spoken poetry.
Just an amazing woman,
founder of the women chefs
and Restaurateurs Association
that we talked about is
near and dear to Dee and myself
as a former board member of that.
So I think once you kind of get started,
then it,
it easier to get the ball rolling. And
that's true of any aspect of creativity.
Um, the good to quote, it's like, you
know, whatever you can imagine, um,
and I won't get the words
right, but, uh, you know, be
bold, take action, and then it,
it really has a magic to it
that really starts to unfold.
So once you take action in a certain
direction, we talk in the book,
there's an atcs,
that section of the book,
the back of the book is
laid out like Flavor Bible.
If any of you are familiar with that where
it's a three column format, uh, a to z.
But instead of flavors, we have apples
to Zucchini in the flavor Bible.
We have every other topic under
the sun from architecture to um,
Alice in wonderland, Alice in wonderland.
There's actually a restaurant based on
some wonderland, the book. And we
actually finished up with a yoga,
Rick Bayless of the frontier grill and
Taco Bompo restaurant of the year on the
James Beard Award.
He's been doing yoga for 20 years and
this is what's fun about knowing these
people for so long. It's like, hey
Rick, would you mind, you know,
doing a yoga pose for us.
So is did his chef's jacket and he was
pops up on the counter and does yoga for
us.
He's amazing for as long as we've known
him because we interviewed Rick Bayless
for all of our books. We had never
seen him do this amazing pose before.
But you know,
anyone's multitalented as you,
as Rick who has been doing yoga for 20
years, it's um, it's pretty awesome.
So what an inspiration to talk to
chefs in it. And again, you know,
when you're talking to chefs for your
11th book as opposed to your first book,
it's a whole different
ballgame because they,
you built up a certain level
of knowledge and trust.
And so we were talking to people about
what inspires them and they went a little
rogue with that. Went there, went there.
And you can tell us quite honestly,
you know,
I look at my ingredients,
I talked to my ingredients and so I'll
take an apple and I'll put it in the
center of the table and I'll have a
conversation with the apple and say, okay,
yeah, Paul, what are we going to do today?
You've done some interesting things
before, but what are we going to do today?
And that there's this level of intuition.
You could call it mediumship,
channeling, whatever you want to call
it, that that takes place. And, uh,
we were talking about the most
respected chefs in the country.
So Jose and is based in Washington, DC.
We'll talk to his ingredients. He said,
if you talk to your ingredients,
they will always tell you a story.
You just have to have your
ears open to hear that story.
Guy Olivera who just won the James
Beard award this year is the best, uh,
outstanding pastry chef
in the United States.
She's the one who puts the apple and
the parchment paper in the center and
Restaurant Danielle in New York City
and says, talk to me, apple, um,
to Phillip Foss from El Ideas in Chicago.
Phillip Foss. He's great. Uh, this is
a very fascinating restaurant. It's,
it's in a loft way out in the middle of
nowhere. They say, take a car, you know,
don't take public transportation.
Um, but he will say,
the ingredient is my child and I want my
child to succeed and be happy and it's
up to me to care for the child and, and
make sure it's a physically, emotionally,
and mentally and spiritually happy.
So he treats his ingredients like
the children and raises them again,
has that conversation and he has the
craziest menu I think I've ever seen.
He will do a menu based on the 80s he
will produce a dish and play a certain
piece of music that is inspired by.
Okay.
Madonna is like a virgin. Like what? Yeah,
that was for the Ada that he'll serve.
Um,
cocaine,
which is basically a lime and coconut
powder on a mirror with the razor blade is
Michelin Star restaurant. I
hear that he's, he's out there,
but he's got a Michelin
Star. He's respected, he's so
celebrated. And so, you know,
there are chefs out
there who are creative.
They're pushing the envelope and they're
doing a lot of things that are a lot of
fun. And you might not serve
exactly the same things at home,
but you can be inspired by the
thought process. He does a job.
He does a dish of
frosties and French fries,
which was inspired by his daughters as
a single dad for a while and raising his
kids and the babysitter took them to
Wendy's where they learned to dip there.
Did anybody do that?
If their French fries and cross,
did you ever have it in a
Michelin starred restaurant?
If you go to El Ideas in Chicago,
you can taste it there.
So, um, what, what I love
about these books again is it,
it's caters to a variety of audiences.
You've got people that are
cooking at home, you've got
people that are beginning,
beginning to look,
cook or learning to cover.
You've got people that are
cooking for many years. And I,
what I love about this in essence is
it's very similar to our program here is
we're really trying to enable people
to pick up skills and give them the
competence. And um, when you,
when you dive into the book,
you're going to see that the quotes
in here are not only from some of the,
the biggest and baddest names out there,
but they're the really great tidbits
that really helps unpack what they're
thinking in their thought process.
So let's think,
let's talk a little bit about the book.
So the book is very interesting.
This is a book of no recipes.
Um, this is a book of,
and thank you because there's a lot of
recipes out there, but it's really around,
um, uh, a few different aspects. So
you start the book around mastery.
And so there's a section on that
which I'd love to talk about briefly.
And then section two is more around
alchemy and the transformation stage.
And then number three is around
really that creativity aspect,
which obviously is the bulk of it.
Can you,
can you talk about the three
different sections, uh,
briefly so we can kind of
get an understanding of why
you went back direction?
Um, and then what we'll
bring in some examples?
Sure. Um, well we start out
with mastery because it's,
Picasso lets us know you can't break
the rules unless you knew what the rules
are. So you start out by
understanding the rules.
And the way to do that is really
to learn to think like a chef shop,
like a chef in season, like a chef. And
so in terms of thinking like a chef,
we have done lots of research on the
leading books that chef's everywhere say
that you should have in your
culinary library at home.
We've narrowed it down to the 20 top
books and if you read these books,
if you really absorbed that information,
you're going to know what the best chefs
know and that will give you a starting
point in terms of knowledge,
in terms of skill you want to learn to.
Well actually one of the things
that's important with the chefs is,
and the shopping aspect of this shopping
is a skill that if you are willing to
invest in the same level of ingredients
that the best chefs work with,
you're not going to have the same results.
Um,
sometimes the hardest part is
figuring out where do you buy it. Um,
and chefs have already done that hard
work for you to find the very best of the
best ingredients.
We have a list of the purveyors that
provide chest with some of the, uh,
hard to find ingredients, spices,
herbs, seasonings, things as,
yes, yeah, lots of grains and
flours. They don't want the, their,
their polenta milled a certain way or
their flour mill the certain way. And so,
um, we've got a guide to
where to shop like a chef.
And then in terms of seasoning,
like a chef,
I mean that's really what we were
talking about it in culinary artistry.
So many years ago when we
banished chefs to a desert island,
asked them to bring only 10 ingredients
that they we cook with for the rest of
their life.
The number one ingredient was salt.
And Salt is really the master technique.
All the chefs in the room are nodding
their heads like, yes, of course. Um,
but to learn to add sodium to addition
a way that enhances flavor without
necessarily adding flavor, which we get
into in the alchemy stage of things.
But um, there it gets a little
more complicated than beyond,
above and beyond the Flavor Bible.
We talk about different elements of salts.
So not just which salty different
chefs use. Some use sea salt,
some use mind salt, some use,
you know, pink salts, you know,
there different salts
for different purposes.
And thinking more specifically
about the salt you use,
adding and adding not only sodium,
but in some cases who mommy threw
a salty ingredient or um, other,
uh, ingredients that are complex that
will add more than one. Taste. It once.
If you learn how to work with them,
it can really elevate your cooking.
We talked to one chef, um, the
other night in New York City,
we did an event and he was talking about
the fact that he was actually ran out
of salt, which was like the first
chef I've ever heard. But it happens,
that's the exact reaction
run out of it at the restaurant.
But at home he opened up his refrigerator
at home and he had fed a cheese there.
So you took the liquid from the federal,
which is salty and he used that as
sort of a liquid salt ad hoc and only,
you know, it's a, it just one
of those things that it's like,
well of course you could use salty
ingredients. It doesn't have to be solved.
And I think part of what cook kitchen
creativity is all about is how can you
open your mind to thinking not
about specific ingredients,
but think of concepts that you're adding
to a dish and to use it and really
extrapolate from there.
It's interesting to think through the
whole aspect of just seasoning because
people think, oh, you just have
solvents done. Well there's,
there's types of salters
layering when to add the salt,
when to add it and not getting
in the end of the fucking light.
And these are the tips that are within
the book that really helped, um, uh,
a good shot, become a great chef and a
great chat, become an excellent chef,
whether again, you're home
chef or not. Um, so the,
the first day just mastery in it, you
made it very clear that, you know,
and all the chefs had this in the book
that to be able to master anything,
it's a lot of practice, a lot of
discipline. It's a lot of time.
And once you understand the rules,
then you can attempt to break the rules.
And then I think it kind of
takes you to that next step.
So talk a little about the next section,
which is around that transformation,
that alchemy stage.
That's the stage that we really been
writing about and talking about four years
now under the guise of culinary artistry,
the Flavor Bible and what
to drink with what you eat.
So I'll give me is really about how do
you take something common and turn it
into something precious.
And what we mean by that is that there
is a benefit in the culinary world that
one plus one doesn't equal two.
There are instances in which one
plus one can equal three or more.
And what we have dedicated our research
too over the years is trying to identify
what is the lock that you can put there,
the key that you can put into the
lock to really turn it to unlock the
deliciousness of particular ingredients,
whether they're herbs or spices or other
seasonings for specific ingredients or
is, and this is what led
us both to some ace school,
is realizing that if you've got a
perfect plate of food in front of you and
you've got the wrong wine in your glass,
when you have the two together,
which you inevitably do because you eat
and drink together, it's going to clash.
It's going to ruin the food.
So we,
we became committed to studying wine and
earning our Sameei certificates because
it was so important to me.
Is it a mass part is an
important way to master flavor.
And that was the best means that we had
to be able to train our palettes and to
learn more about what, what was the secret
to matching the best wines with food.
And so we also interviewed dozens of the
best someways all across the country,
including it,
some of the top restaurants and people
that you're well acquainted with and
really compiled that into what
to drink with what you eat,
which is the ultimate food
and wine pairing guide.
Because you can look up the food, it
will tell you what wine or beer, spirits,
cocktails, water, coffee,
tea or etc. To drink with it,
to enhance the flavor of that food.
Vice versa.
If you're starting with a bottle of wine,
you're starting with a beer,
you're starting with something else,
what food can you serve with it to best
enhance what's in the bottle or what's
in the glass. And so when you bring
all of those elements together,
that's what really what we're
talking about in terms of alchemy.
If you master some of the principles
of what are the key flavor pairings,
what are the key, you know, so the,
some of those standard, you know,
son Sarah Oysters or peanut
and Anwar and salmon. Um,
if you master some of those,
it gets you so close to the ballpark
that you could actually be only okay chef
with a modicum of talent.
But if you understand those principles
and can apply them in the kitchen,
it's going to make you
shine to a whole new level.
Yeah,
and I always,
we always talk about thinking about
what's in the glass as a sauce also.
And again,
you know,
a really easy way to do that quick
tool as if it grows together,
it goes together.
So if you're in Italy and you're
making pasta from northern Italy,
see what they drink in northern Italy,
if you're in the bay area and
you're grilling a steak or gosh,
I have a bottle of this end,
you know,
the right there in Napa valley and
they're all next to each other.
There's a natural synergy.
But also I think it's also funded,
and just wrap this part up a little bit,
is that it's not just wine.
You can,
you have a lemon soda with a salad and
that could almost be your dressing on a
salad. So you think outside just
the classic pairings. And like,
we all know that you can actually
drink white wine with many things.
You can actually drink red
wine with fish now it's okay.
Peanut and Warren Salmon. So think
you know, of all the beverages,
what do you can bring in?
And again,
that's going to change a of meals
just by having the proper beverage.
You know, that's, that's the three there.
I think you hit on a lot of a lot of
key points and it goes much deeper than
just the actual dish itself. It goes to
what's being paired at your surrounding.
And it creates that experience that if
any of you think about your most epic
food experience you've ever had,
it couldn't be a hotdog at the ballpark.
It could be at a Michelin Star restaurant.
There's different things
that all came together.
Absolutely a great culinary and
makes that look so easy. And Zach,
a lot of these tips are in the book
and so it's super, super exciting.
There's a great quote in the book and it
starts off by saying, um, you know, to,
to not copy other shots, but
to be able to get inspired. I,
and many others feel that copying
is actually the gateway to get into.
Can you speak to that because
it's kind of a contradiction,
but it actually makes total sense.
Yeah. Smell that that's
sort of the, the, you know,
Hook in the beginning of the book is
talking about we want to teach you
creativity. What's the definition
of creativity? It's not copying,
coming up with something that's
new and useful and surprising.
And yet by definition, how do you get
to that point of being able to do it?
You need to learn the rules.
How do you learn the rules you'd copy.
So that's the push me pull you.
And I think that that is a lesson that
comes through time and time again in the
book and that it's never one or the
other. It's never a hot versus cold. It's,
it's both. And, and we talk, um,
in the back of the book under why you'll
find yes and being one of the key rules
that you need to master for creativity.
And if it's the first
rule of improvisation,
if you've ever done any
improvisational acting,
you know that if someone
says something like, okay,
here's the premise of this scene,
I'm going to walk in and you know,
I dropped the book on the floor.
Uh, you don't say, oh no, no, no,
you didn't drop the book. You'd have
to say yes, you dropped the book.
And that was the book that I was on,
the wait list for it. The library.
It's like yes.
And um,
that was the book that my
ex boyfriend actually wrote.
And you,
you add onto the story.
So you always add onto it because
you never want to break that chain.
So the key that you can take from the
improvisation or rules and to apply in the
kitchen is, or no matter what happens,
you trust that it's there to serve you.
And it's for a reason. And what we
tell people is, it kind of goes,
if you at in the beginning of the book,
there's a list of ingredient of different
classic dishes and what their origins
were. And a lot of times
they came from mistakes.
So there was something that went wrong.
You know,
the Burrito Burrito gets knocked into
the deep fat fryer. Hey Jimmy. John Goes,
or the, the Ravioli gets knocked
into the deep fat fryer. Hey,
toasted Ravioli turns into a thing.
People love it. So it's never,
things are never really mistakes
that if you pay attention to it,
and so it pressman and
wolves in San Francisco,
the intern under cooks the egg
that you asked her to hard boil.
It's soft boil. It oozes out. Wait
a second, that's kind of cool.
And you find out that people love
things that who's out of other things,
all the secrets out of our,
our mistakes,
right? I think front Adria talks in
the book about the fact that, um, you,
if you're unique and if you're doing
something innovative that no one else has
done before and you're not copying,
and then no one can really
judge it against anything else.
And I think that's a good point.
But you cannot go that direction unless
you've got the understanding of the
technique and the master to begin with.
And obviously if Rhonda is one of
the most acclaimed chefs out there,
and so he can,
he can easily pull that off.
But I think it's a great testament to
get inspired by seeing what other people
do, have conversations, whatever your
inspiration is this the document you do,
you have a lot of great tips in the book
around how do you capture that moment
of creativity?
It's about always being positive.
It's about surrounding yourself
with others on great conversations.
It's about writing things down.
And you know, most most chefs,
great chefs have either
a, you know, a pocket book
and a notebook right by the
bedside because Brian, you wait
cup sometimes you've had this
amazing thought. Or for me it's,
if I exercise it's like I get that mom
moment of that would work and they,
you know,
you have to write it down and it's
about all these great little tips that
sometimes are not revolutionary. It's
just, yes, this makes total sense.
Let's do this more often. And you can
take that outside the kitchen as well.
Yes.
And that was one of the benefits of being
able to do book number 11 is because
chefs were really up front with us about
their creative process involving, um,
in a lot of cases,
a personal reflection time.
So whether that was through
journaling or through meditation,
we found out that a lot of the chefs
we've been talking to for years where
you're very deep meditators, um, talk
with Eric repair of Laverne or down,
which is on the world's
50 best restaurants list
about his Tibetan Buddhist
meditation practice that he credits as a
source of his creativity. Mario Batali,
who was studied TM after being recommended
to it by Jerry Seinfeld of all people.
Um, and so he studied through the
David Lynch Foundation. Um, and uh,
other chefs are big meditators,
yoga doers, martial artists,
a runners.
Because for those of us who are runners,
like Andrew and I have run marathons.
When you're doing 26.2 miles, you know,
it's all mental. It's not
physical anymore. So like
business, it's very, very, uh, you bring
out all your senses when you're cooking.
How many people here love to cook at
home? All right, I kind of figured it,
you're going to be so more inspired
now this, but, um, when it brings out,
it brings out all, all of it and it's
very draining. It's emotionally draining,
sometimes more than even physically
draining depending on what you're doing.
And I think that,
you know,
whatever you need to do to create that
balance is going to keep you at your best
so that you can be at your best
consistently. Because, you know,
working with men and if we're not
feeling creative that speaks in the
[inaudible], you can see it.
You can, you can smell it,
you can taste it or you can't.
Right.
And when you look at,
he calls that the aura of a dish where
you know that the most important aspect
of the dishes,
that connection between the dish itself
and the person who's eating it. Sure.
And she believes it's love that you can
actually taste it if there's Solon a
dish, if there's love in a dish or
if there's not, if a dish falls flat,
she knows that people are just started
cooking with everything that they can
bring to a dish.
Sure.
So we're going to do a transition here
and speaking of bringing everything that
we can to a dish, we're going to do a
little fun year with eating and the team.
So we're in the kitchen sink, a teaching
kitchen at Google and Sunnyvale.
And the team here is going
to talk through, we're going
to move the chairs out.
They're going to talk through kind of
how they look at inspiration when they
create meals and recipes for our Googlers.
If they teach them to cook. And a,
it will be a kind of narrating back
and forth and asking her all sorts of
questions and seeing how it comes to
light. But we're excited for this.
So chef dd, welcome. Thank you.
Let me get out of your way.
So tell the audience here and obviously
our virtual audience a little bit about
what you do and what kitchen sink
is for the folks in the audience,
they probably understand it, but
you're, you're delivering, uh,
cooking classes to Googlers. Yes.
Sometimes families, sometimes families.
And you're teaching people
on a variety of spectrum,
whether they know how to
cook the comfortable with
cooking or, or not at all.
Yup. Um, sometimes we have people
that cook six, seven nights a week,
sometimes the just getting into the
kitchen and they want some basic knife
skills and basic cooking techniques.
So, um, we have a full culinary program.
Single subject classes could be
who literacy based skill building.
Um, we do a core culinary
program, lots of team events,
um, guest chefs. So, um, usually
two classes a day or more.
I do have the coolest job on campus.
I get to live in this amazing space
every day. And you're in a
brand new teaching kitchen here.
So I'm gonna move the
chair out of your way.
And why don't you just talk a
little bit about, I know that,
I know I have a kind of an understanding
of what you're looking through here,
but I was talking to Karen and Andrew
earlier about what I call the chefs'
arsenal. And the chefs' arsenal
for many shops is expected,
especially in the older days when
we were trained as you've got sugar,
you've got salt, you've got
fat, whatever that fat might be.
And those are the three things that
typically dominate and deliver flavor.
And we still use those, but we use
them a lot more thoughtfully. Um,
we have a very intentional look, uh,
outlook on the food program at Google. Uh,
and we want,
while we want to deliver on deliciousness,
I love the fact that you said that,
and that's in the book.
We want to deliver on deliciousness.
We can do this in thoughtful ways.
And so you're going to talk through your
dish today and kind of how you're doing
that with the Google twist.
Um,
and talk through some of the ingredients
that are your modern day arsenal that
are still delivering on the
attributes of sweet sugar.
Salt and fat,
you're doing them in a thoughtful way.
Um, yeah. So one of the things I think
about when I'm building out a dish, um,
let's start with seasonality. I
think that's really important. Um,
and I'm thinking about the dish today.
Um,
I just was thinking about all these
amazing fall squashes that are coming into
the market.
So roasted up some butternut squash.
We have some Delicata squash
roasted as well. And then,
um, thinking about, um, other ingredients
that would go well with this dish.
So,
um,
some Nice Kale mushrooms and not
only mushrooms, roasted mushrooms,
so some roasted Shataki
mushrooms really get into
super tasty salty Umami for sure,
roasting a lot. And I, and I don't,
for those that can't see
the ingredients up close,
you're developing a
heightened sense of the,
of the flavor of why the caramelization
of the natural sugars in the squash and
the mushrooms. You're extracting the
water to get more flavor. And so you're,
you're really delivering on flavor.
And most of this,
if not all of this has it all plant based.
And so you're highlighting the seasonality
as we're heading into fall. Um,
we have some of the squashes here,
but you've got some staples
that are always on our menus,
whether it's the chemo,
why are the mushrooms and things like
that, a roasted shallots as well. So yeah,
really nice plant based dish, not
one of the things. We also um,
driving kitchen sink as
well. And then, yeah,
thinking about you could take this set
of ingredients and then I think about,
okay, how am I going to build flavor, um,
with a sauce or the dressing
or the sparkling water or
the wine. Right. So, um,
today I wanted to take a kind of a,
a trip and a map to uh,
Thailand and use some Thai
ingredients. Okay. Excellent. Um,
so things like fish sauce,
right,
salty, Umami. It's that layer
of salt that's not just,
just solid caramelization too.
A lot of flavor in there. Um,
soy sauce. Um, another, no Fermin,
fermented sauces, fermented
flavors, really rich in Umami. Um,
palm sugar, a little bit of sweet,
but also bill nuts. Yeah. Right? Yes.
Um,
Kinda caramely Vanilli not just that
plain white sugar thing happening out
there.
Um,
fresh ginger or classically
for tag along the route.
Um,
Thai chilies,
a little bit of that heat and that sensory
that you want to pause you right now,
right
now because of what you're,
you're,
you've delivered on so many attributes
that are so important to any rate meal.
And obviously within our,
our guidance that we provide where chefs,
we have a saying called flavor roles,
flavor rules.
It has to be there or why bother
just go home and pack it up.
But there's also rules of flavor and with
DDS talked about is you've got amazing
flavors here and happened to be
plant based. They don't have to beat,
you've gotten a mommy
that sixth sense of that,
that neediness through machines soy saw.
So you've got the spice through ginger,
you've got spice through Saracho or Chili,
you've got the herbaceousness
from the Cilantro,
you've got the crunch from the nuts.
You've got all these different aspects
that for a district truly be craveable
for you to want one more bite. You need
to get all of these elements together.
And what dd is going to do now is to
pull these together in a way that, um,
is going to want the diner to go back for
that next bite. And as our focus here,
we're,
we're trying to help our users make
better choices with food because the food
here is something that is
plentiful and bountiful.
It's easy to make wrong decisions and
our job is to make it easier for you to
make better choices and
to enjoy what you had.
Because a lot of times users come to us
and say, this is the highlight of my day.
Lunch was like the highlight. So it
should be, it should be me experience.
Hopefully not. No one's saying no or yes,
there's audience has questions.
You guys can chime in while dd
starts putting this together.
You picked some of my favorite
compliments to. Uh, I,
I love this combination
of squash and mushrooms,
the earthiness balancing
the sweetness of the squash.
I think it's still seasonal
and yet there's a real
complimentary nature to that
and actually do that.
I thing I like is the fact that the
nuts, the nuts, we'll add crunch,
but also it's protein and it's fast.
So when you were talking about fat being
such as playing a role and it still
does and fat is actually soon
to be considered a flavor,
but that's a good way to make the dish
even healthier as opposed to like a
creamy dressing or something like that.
You can get it all there.
So you're actually getting two for one.
Actually a little bit of a mommy too.
So that's a really key thing. And if he
doesn't like print them nuts, it's like
walnuts. You know how we were talking
about earlier that kind of stealing that,
taking it nice and it's a check out the
book of course, before you got here,
how was like, right, I've got to put
the mushrooms in there, so thank you.
I basically read well and your tension
and of course King Wah with it's high
protein content. Always feel virtuous
when I have it. I love the texture.
It's more of a textural thing for me,
I think then flavor,
but I love the earthiness of it.
Um,
knowing that I'm doing something
good for my writing, right.
There's a beautiful array of
colors for those that are up here.
You can smell it and it's a cold dish.
So imagine if some of these words were
heated and you could easily add your warm
mushrooms are warm. Squash and temperature
plays a lot into what we do as we're,
you know, creating dishes because
you eat with your eyes first,
but you even before that is if you
walk into any cafe or restaurant,
the first thing you generally
get is a smell of something.
And hopefully it's something that's,
you know,
not overpowering like Cologne or perfume,
which is why chefs don't wear,
it's beautiful, which is why chefs
don't wear that. So refreshing.
One of the things that I loved,
needed to speak to is the,
the disciplines within the program of
Google about really practicing your
recipes. I mean this is something
that you've made before.
Not something that you see on top
shop where you get five ingredients,
you put something together.
That's perfect day one.
And the reason I mentioned that and I
love that the TV shows that have really
brought the popularity of food
and getting more people excited,
but at times I think there's a challenge
out there that a lot of people think
that just throwing ingredients together
is, is the way it is for shops.
And that's not the case.
They spent so much time testing and
training and retesting and retooling and
what we call a signature recipe.
It might take us weeks, months,
or years to get to a point and talk a
little bit about your thought process of
how you got this,
cause I know you just didn't go in
their fridge or if you're like, ah,
that looks like fun, but you had some
bought with this. So let us give us some,
some insights as you're compiling mixed
fleets. Yeah, absolutely. So like I said,
back to, um, seasonality,
um, deliciousness,
craveability um, you know, super
important. And so, you know,
going back to, you know, roasting the
butternut squash, um, thinking about,
um, the fish sauce, all
those fermented things.
I'm actually surprised I didn't put me so
paste on this because
I'm obsessed with me,
so it's always better with me sir,
but often better with me. Great.
The magic ingredient a little bit
with salad dressing or um, you
know, adding it into a dish.
What do you said about roasting
the squash? Because again,
every ingredient also has a key that
unlocks it in terms of technique.
You don't boil it, steam it, roast
it to get the ultimate flavor.
Yeah, great point. Um, you
know, adding in the crunch with,
with some of the red bell peppers
and also a little bit of sweetness.
We roasted the shallots as well.
Nothing concepts in the book.
And then, you know, we balanced taste
right, the sweet, the sour, the salty,
the bitter and Umami. So it's like chefs
favorite two words need salt. Yeah. Yeah.
I think even in the book,
like people,
people new joke that the chest can look
at a dish and say it needs salt in nine
times out of 10 the right.
Yeah.
So you're about to put this together
and obviously the team is in right now
Jerrod's tasting nutritious,
that it's so key.
How many people here have, have cooked
at home. And there's always something.
There's that one little element missing,
right? It could be salt, it could be acid,
it could be that balance.
And that's the fun in,
in the kitchen is to come up with what
is that perfect balance that you're
looking for and what would DDS got here
is a perfect opportunity to deliver on
amazing, delicious, because
you've got all that going on.
But what Thai food specifically, it's
either really good or really wrong, right?
Because if you're too high on the sugar,
if you too high on the spice,
it just throws the balance off, right?
And so what she's doing now, it's,
she's going through and she's
looking for those, those, uh,
specific balances and incorporating
the ingredients. How's it tasting?
Good.
Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee checked that.
I think with the sweetness,
sweetness gets a bad rap that you
don't want to eat too much sugar,
which I think is true,
but also sometimes all you need is a
little bit of sugar to be a enhancer and
you get, and there's that peak, um, aspect
of when you're looking at how to season,
where you learn, okay, it's,
it's, it's enhancing place.
Enhancing has upset starts stalling
flavor. And so if you add too much sugar,
it will do all the flavors.
So you kind of have to work on
getting to the peak of that apex.
But is it still going up in the new four?
It starts going down and I think that's
just a matter of trial and error.
Repetition, as you said before,
personal tastes in some instances.
Yeah. And that's a challenge. A
personal taste obviously with, you know,
hundreds of thousands of
dollars running around.
What are our approach on that is to
create food that is approachable for
everyone but personalizable
for everyone as well.
And so a lot of the time will be
garnished is on the side purposely.
So that people can add their element of,
of acidity is spice, et cetera. Um, and,
and I find myself doing that more and
more when I cook at home is because
everyone has different tastes. So a
question for you, for both of you,
if you had three ingredients that are
always in your refrigerator that you would
rely on
and it always changes, right?
Absolutely. Cases during the season.
Two we'd have to have me
sit, well champagne, I don't
know about that ingredient
is getting importance.
It is always in the original
parmesan cheese Parmesan is a world
war horse because we ate Vegan for two
months and we've found that it was really
hard to live without Parmesan. Sure.
Why would you want to do that? Yeah. Yeah.
All right. We still farmers on, cause I'm,
I'm picking up
Jesus Umami name. Okay. And then
actually none of the refrigerator on the,
on the next month or next to the stove
as I always have a wide variety of
winners. Champagne, Sherri Balsamic,
white Balsamic, dark balsamic.
And what's cool about vinegars?
I think this is the,
if you want to be more creative tonight
by a different bottle of vinegar,
make each same salad and do a one
with balsamic vinegar tonight,
one with a squeeze of lemon tomorrow
and one was champagne vinegar.
The next day you'll have three completely
different salads and also vinegar,
seven different degrees of acidity to so
champagnes and he was very soft lemons
role. It's always off. So we
always have a lot of vinegar.
So it's sort of basically salt sour.
Actually it says own sauce. Oh, okay.
Touch your skin. Says we've got
a little bottle of that, uh,
after we leave feeling
inspired to cook tonight. Yeah.
The thing is is that if you have those
key ingredients, whatever they are,
and I think it changes from week to week
because we don't like having the same
thing every night. So some
nights it's like, okay,
we better have rice and beans and Avocados
because that'll get us in the Mexican
realm. We want to have a good salsa
on hand or either a fresh, uh, uh,
pick up the guy a or a great,
uh,
jarred salsa and just be being able
to throw those elements together very
quickly so that you can eat in a different
country every night of the week if
you've got or every week.
You can sort of shake it up if you
want to use over some leftovers.
But when we are in a pasta mood, we want
to have pasta on hand. Um, Olana Pesto,
we love the combination of pasta,
pesto beans.
If you know it's one of those 10,
15 minute meals that you boil up the
pasta. If you, sometimes you even,
even authors who write about food,
don't want to be that ambitious to
do an got to be, that takes an hour.
You just want something, okay, I want
something delicious and one in 15 minutes.
Right? The combination of the Pesto
and wiping and pasta is a staple.
And then we throw in some Greens because
you want to have some nutritional value
in there. So she's a good one for smart
kitchen. It's expenditure different.
Going into a pasta and go into
a salad can go into a curry.
I stuff when I got that,
I was looking at this really what made
this dish special is the fact that dad
decided to take it to Thailand.
I smells great, but look,
if I looked at these ingredients fall,
yeah, I could easily turn this into Chile.
You know like this be, this will be my
Chilean home. Swash Greens, mushrooms,
beans. Yeah. Bands you can go
to a completely different place.
So the question we'll use
at night is like, well,
what country do I feel
like being in tonight?
And often sometimes it's a split because
one of us is researching one thing and
when this is research and the other
thing it's like, oh, he has it.
Have couscous was, I've been
reading about Moroccan food all day.
It's like couscous, why would
you want couscous? You need,
you need noodles tonight.
So that's always a music question
to ask yourself. It's like,
what country do I want to be
in? And then it's like, okay,
then you go in and grab
everything you have at a huh.
Super Fun. Super Fun. So DDS
plating the demonstration played
up in the team behind you.
I'm just gonna play that.
The samples,
what I'd like to do now is to open it
up to any questions that we might have
while the,
the authors are here and finishing up
the plate up and then we'll have a quick
sampling and then we'll do a
book signing after that. Uh,
so if there are initial questions to
start racing your hands, um, if not,
I'll just keep gathering because I don't
think I don't have this opportunity
often.
Yes,
just start.
It's totally meant to be flipping
through it. You flipped through a to z.
Anything that catches your attention,
it catches your attention for a reason.
I think flipping through it is the
absolute best way to read the book.
You can read it chronologically,
it's laid out in a chronological manner,
but you don't have to,
I would say pick it up whenever you need
inspiration and we wrote it to be there
for when you do.
So the question just to
repeat it for the audience,
that oil on video is that it is or a
starting point in the book and I think you
captured the graders.
There could be but it doesn't have to be
and I think that that would be the same
for many of the books that you have is
I literally was in culinary Igert street
just a few days ago,
not because of the fact you were here,
but I had some questions just around
ingredients study to write for a menu for
the Montana event and I need a little
inspiration and I was not feeling creative
at the moment. Help
me, Karen, help me out.
And so you can definitely use those
books at anytime as resources and I think
what you're going to find in this one,
did you indeed do that even more so
because there's so much good stuff in here
with all the chef tips, the quotes,
amazing. No additional questions from the,
from the audience
in the front and then
we'll go to the back. Yes.
How did you season the roasted vegetables?
Yeah,
just a little bit of olive
oil and salt and pepper.
So really simple that way you could really
take this base dish here in a variety
of direction. So, um, if I was
feeling more Mediterranean today,
I could have done lemons and Federer,
Parmesan and or some champagne vinegar,
maybe some Bazell.
Um,
so keeping your sort of
my core roadmap simple.
Plus we have leftovers.
Today's tie tomorrow can be submitted
to ade and it's like a whole new dish we
season at home for the exact same reasons.
You want the flexibility if you want to
be in a different country the next day.
If you season it upfront with
something that's very identifiable,
but this specific cuisine
you're going to have,
you're going to stay in that country
the next day and the next day is it up?
We never call it leftovers. We
call it the encores. We are,
it's like, yeah, you just,
some of that a little bit,
it's really interesting to add your
question is I know what you're getting at,
which is, you know, what do I need
to do to get to that end result?
And you know you could use butter,
you could oil,
oil doesn't really matter at this point.
You obviously chose oil because it's
neutral and it's a little lighter fat,
but what you've done really
well in this is the technique.
You've found a way to diocese in a way
that they're consistent size so they're
going to cook evenly.
You found a way to brown them off
so that they still have texture and
caramelization but they're not
mushy nor are they crunchy.
These are the things that make or break
a great meal and take a little bit of
time to to think through
but nice job on that.
There was a question in the back and
we're going to repeat the question just so
we can get it on
the entire process.
The entire process when it comes
to the research for our books.
And this one in particular,
you know, we, for this book,
we had both a bottom up and a top down
approach where the bottom up approach was
basically talking to chefs about what
they felt was important to know about
their creative process,
about how they cook and all of them have
different specialties is some of them
have different countries
that they specialize or
different techniques that they
specialize in something that roots their
cuisine and makes it different from
anyone else's.
And so we wanted to understand from
talking to Kyle cannot at single thread
about his influences and working in Japan
and that Japanese sensibility that he
brings to his food in conjunction to the
crazy stuff that he's doing with Heston
Blumenthal and that
he'd learned at elderly.
We're working in elderly,
so he sort of brings it all together
in a really interesting way.
Other people like Rick Bayless from
Frontera Grill in Chicago is much more
specialized in Mexican cuisine.
And so we wanted to really
understand that by talking to Rick,
we talked to his chef to cuisine,
but we really wanted to understand
their approach to thinking about things.
And the beautiful thing about it is that
when you talk to people who are at the
best of the best at what they do,
they've been doing it in
some cases for decades.
And that creativity is
reflected in evolution.
That their cuisine goes through the
evolution of their thought process,
where they're designing a new menu and
had brainstormed a list of adjectives
that best described certain dishes.
So they organize their menu not
by appetizer, entree and dessert,
but by characteristic.
So it shows the level of thought
process that they put into it.
They're also used inspiration by d of
different paintings and different works of
art in their restaurant.
It will come up with dishes that are
reflect reflection of that. So, um,
the research is extensive in
terms of speaking to chefs.
We also do extensive research
on a restaurant reviews,
trying to understand
their restaurants from it,
from a local critic's perspective.
We reviewed their cookbooks,
we view their menus.
Um,
and then we kind of put it all together
and kind of bring it all together.
We also studied creativity from
the ex, uh, from the point of view,
various experts on creativity.
So we spoke to experts like Michael Gal,
the author of how to think like Leonardo
Da Vinci and the art of connection on
how do you, uh, really bring
those elements of creativity,
what are the things that
we should be looking for?
And he is identified some of the key
genius thinking attributes of Leonardo Da
Vinci. We saw them in the
world's most creative chefs.
And so I think through that,
um, opportunity of really
bringing the two together,
we saw how chefs,
we're the perfect exemplars of some of
the best creativity that's going on in
the world today and to really take a look
at their best practices and really try
to translate that for anyone, whether
it's a professional chef or a home cook,
um, to help you to be more creative when
you least feel the inspiration to be
creative.
So we have one,
one or two more questions.
So one thing that I'm taking away from
this and I hoping you are as well as the
thought and to intentionality,
depending on whoever you are that's
creating something is immense.
And when you are preparing your next
meal or when you're at a restaurant,
I would say when you're preparing your
own meal or someone else's cooking for
you specifically, get home, turn off
the TV, turn off the distractions,
and take a few minutes to
really be mindful of the
experience that someone else
has prepared for you or that
you prepared for yourself.
And the reason I mentioned that,
and this is in the book as well,
is music and other distractions can
either enhance or completely detract from
the experience and knowing the thought
that went into just something as simple
as a salad. And this is not a simple
dish and it was delicious by the way,
that roasted mushroom,
the winning,
the winning hook there that got me to
go through x bite was that mushroom.
But think about that as you're,
as you're creating things and have a
conversation with people when you're
cooking for them.
Because this is what it's all about.
And the reason I mentioned turning down
the TV is it so easy just to be mindless
and just, you know,
it's not dining anymore,
it's just kind of feeding
and we all do that at a time.
But thank you for all the
work that you've done here.
Was there another couple of questions
before we line up for signatures?
Yes.
So we have some big
occasions.
Great
question. You know, a lot of
times it's, it's very personal.
I mean the holidays are times that we
need to get together with family or
friends, loved ones. And there's a lot of
childhood memories that are involved. Um,
Andrew and I, our families had different
stuffings when we were growing up.
Sit down. We have a multiple stuffing
celebration, um, this time of year.
But a lot of times, you know, there's a
sacredness. You don't always want to be.
Creativity isn't always a good
thing. You know, Daniel Ballou says,
if you're making steak free,
you let it be steak free.
You don't want to get too
creative with that. Um,
and sometimes there's sacred cows
are sacred turkeys when it comes to
thanksgiving,
then he don't want to mess with.
They do want to have a happy
Thanksgiving and you know,
have it be as peaceful and calm
around the table as possible.
You don't want to mess with
people's favorite dishes,
but there are times that you can take
what the essence of Thanksgiving is. And,
uh, if you can deconstruct what is
it that's important to you? Well,
I want to have some pumpkin
dessert on the table.
It doesn't have to be Pumpkin Pie. And
then you can start playing with it. Okay.
Am I going to do a pump and tart?
Am I going to do a Pumpkin Ravioli?
Am I going to make it a side dish? You
know, how am I going to play with that?
Am I going to come up with a pumpkin
cocktail? So you can have, you know,
there's a place in New York
City where we had, um, a,
a Turkey sandwich that was served
with a bag of sweet potato chips and a
cranberry fizzy drink.
And you realize all the flavors
of Thanksgiving or right there,
but they're in a completely
different format. If you
can take the, figure it out,
you know,
do the deconstruction of what are the
flavors that me Christmas to you or
Hanukkah to you or Thanksgiving to you
and narrow them down. And it's like, okay,
well I have to have stuffing or I have
to have gravy or whatever your thing is.
Sorry. Or should always champagne.
Oh, right. So, you know,
you can,
you can play with that.
We have an exercise in the beginning of
Stage three in the book where we ask you
to think about what your five favorite
childhood dishes were and to really
analyze the information
that's packed in there.
Because we think that all of you know
more than you think, you know, um,
and it's all packed in your
favorite childhood dishes.
So if you take a minute and just sort
of make a mental note and it's like,
oh yeah, my mom's blank,
or my grandmother's blank,
or my father is blank.
When he pulled up the grill and made
this for me when I was growing up,
I forgot what those dishes were.
And then think about what
made the dish special to you.
So for me it was caramel apples.
And you'll see a caramel apple example
of different dishes you can make with the
combination of apple caramel and nuts
that are other than a whole apple on a
step. So we've got a solid example.
We've got a cocktail example, um,
different desserts,
you know,
an upscale Dysart example using that
same set of flavor affinities or flavor
chords as we called them,
but in a whole different way.
And if you take that simple example and
you apply it to whatever your favorite
flavors are,
whether it's tomato basil and a
Parmesan cheese or something completely
different garlic,
ginger and soy sauce,
you can take that set of compatible
flavors and apply it to a whole host of
different dishes. And that will
get your creativity going big
quickly. And I would just add one
more thing is that, uh, for like,
it's like w please Thanksgiving
because that's a biggie. Um,
when you make your cranberry sauce, take
half of it and make it a different way.
So have your, have the one
that's gonna make everyone happy.
Thanksgiving for God sake.
But maybe take another one and look up
cranberries and think about cranberries
and like, I don't think I'll
pop some ginger in there,
maybe a little tumeric and I'm a little
orange zest and that might not be your
family's typical one,
but then you're have something new.
And we went vegetarian five years ago,
um, and we were invited to thanksgiving.
So guess what, I learned how
to make mushroom gravy that
year and now, and again,
they'll go on five years. I'm still
working on mushroom gravy, mushroom gravy,
mushroom gravy. So getting this ad you
don't have, have the classic thing there,
the big,
again,
it makes everyone happy but then just
don't a couple extra dishes and was like,
what's two extra dishes at Thanksgiving?
You know, you sort of pointed out like,
this is new, let's, you know, and
that's also a fun way to do it,
because also we'll give you a chance to
sort of chill out around Thanksgiving
and make something New York already
in the kitchen anyway, you know?
But just do have,
excellent,
well, I know we're at time. I
know there's more questions. Uh,
what I'd like to do is first give both
of you a huge round of applause for
coming.
Thank you.
Great.